[Music]
in myth she was called the
Redeemer do you know the story of the
princess
Issa it was said this child would stop
the madness of
War I was given memories of a world I
will never
see loyalty to a King I cannot
serve that she was to usher in a new age
of peace and
[Music]
compassion and love for a
child I could not
save
I found
her scar
Giver what do you think they
want everything I am a child of
War I was taught that love is
weakness
[Applause]
one
moment I do love this
part there is a difference between
Justice and
revenge there is a price to pay for your
Defiance hold
on but I don't want no trouble we're not
here to bring
any let's show them that we're not
afraid
let's show them we are more than the
shackles that bind us are you
ready you and I both know
[Music]
[Applause]
fear the time has come for all that you
love a king is a man and a man can
fail but a myth is
indestructible protect each other we
show them no
[Music]
mercy
who among you is willing to die for what
you
[Applause]
believe welcome back everyone it's
Charlie Zack Snyder just dropped a brand
new Rebel Moon trailer for the Netflix
movie that's coming out later this year
it's actually part one of part two I'll
explain what's going on with the two
different parts because one of the
reasons why they release the trailer at
Gamescom is because they're releasing a
game based on the events of the two
movies it'll be set after the events of
those so I'll explain that too if you're
brand new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos of
course I'll do more trailer videos as
they release them but we're also getting
Ahsoka episodes tonight I'll be doing
videos for that as well so be sure to
enable alerts from my channel so you
don't miss any of that stuff funny
coincidence because a lot of this movie
was inspired by Zack Snider's original
Star Wars movie that he had developed
for Lucas film before he started the SN
verse of DC movies back when the Man of
Steel movie when he was on stage
announcing the trailer he talked a
little bit about other influences too
like that classic Heavy Metal magazine
he liked the vibe of that everybody
remembers The Heavy Metal movie it's a
classic just in general the whole vibe
the tone just the look the feel of the
movie is inspired by Seven Samurai
Kurosawa films which Star Wars films as
well but Star Wars itself George Lucas
said was inspired by classic kurasawa
films a lot of you have commented that
you're seeing a lot of battle beyond the
stars influences in here too the whole
idea is that you have this evil empire
like the empire in Star Wars there's an
emperor so to speak played by Carrie
elways what it looks like is going on in
the trailer is that Sophia Bella's core
character who's sort of the protagonist
puts together this ragtag group of
people who all used to be members of the
Empire's military either generals or
soldiers or just various people
throughout their military and for
whatever reason they all left at some
point like something tragic something
terrible happened or the Empire made
them do something terrible usually it
involves killing a bunch of innocent
people pretty much the same vibe that
you get from the Empire in Star Wars
during the original trilogy so no
coincidence that we're actually seeing
the resurrection of the Empire with
thrawn in the Ahsoka series episodes
starting tonight pretty sure Zack Snyder
didn't intend to time things that way on
purpose just a big coincidence the first
movie is coming out later this year
that's what this trailer footage is for
part one is called child of a fire which
is probably a reference to korus
Childhood in the circumstances of her
rise I don't know this is necessarily
meant to be from her backstory but this
could be a reference to that something
similar could have happened to her like
she came from a world that the Empire
destroyed and she just became a member
of their military there are a lot of
sci-fi a lot of fantasy story lines that
are similar to this where like the
character finds out what really happened
what their origin really was and how The
Empire wronged them and eventually she
Rebels against them Zack Snyder also
made a lot of Dirty Dozen references
just a ragtag group of people that she
winds up putting together some of them
used to be members of the Empire's
military some of them not Rebel Moon
part two is coming out next year it's
called the scar Giver also probably
referenced to Kora maybe a name she was
given when she was a soldier of the
empire in scenes like this it stars
Charlie hunam jimond hansu Anthony
Hopkins Sophia patella whole bunch of
familiar faces that you see like Ed
screen velt was a settlement known
mostly for farming it's where the heroes
of Rebel Moon started their Journey when
the Imperium arrived for their food Ray
Fisher is playing Daren blood ax
alongside his sister Deborah their low
resource resistance Fighters Charlie
hunam is playing Kai he's a mercenary
jond hu's General Titus was an Imperium
general or former General who turned on
the world he once defended to live a sad
life fighting in a Coliseum his
experience being a general in their
forces scarred him causing him to leave
and become a gladiator he was a former
Ally of Kora so when she's looking to
defend velt from the Imperium he's the
first person that she goes to Michelle
hman is playing Gunner he's another
farmer living on Belt that becomes part
of their resistance Carrie elways of all
people is playing the king of the
Galactic Empire like the king of the
Imperium fra free is playing the Regent
bisaria he's the leader of the Imperium
invasion Ed screen is playing the
Admiral Noble who's another leader in
their forces these really crazy looking
people behind them in these awesome
costumes are called scribes they're part
of a religious group on the Imperium
home World Tas with writing down the
history of the Galaxy within the
universe of Rebel Moon they call the
imperium's Home World mother world but a
lot of the history that the scribes
write down is influenced by the politics
of the Imperium so they aren't always
necessarily writing down the true
history of the Galaxy the shirtless dude
here with the crazy ABS is TK he was a
member of a noble family in the Imperium
but after his family had a run with
Mother World tck wind up owing a life
debt to a Rancher for whom he worked as
an indentured servant HonorBound to see
out his debt so when Kora is going
around trying to recruit resistance
Fighters he initially refuses but
eventually agrees to join them the movie
is about a peaceful Colony on the edge
of the Galaxy that's threatened by the
armies of a tyrannical Regent named
belisarius The Desperate civilians
dispatch a young woman who has
mysterious past to seek out Warriors
from nearby planets to help them
challenge the region Anthony Hopkins is
playing Jimmy he's a robot knight this
character here and Sophia batella is
playing the titular Kora who's going
around trying to defend the planet but I
don't think her name Kora was inspired
by Kora from The Legend of Kora in the
Avatar Universe Netflix also just
released a teaser trailer for their
liveaction avatar the Last air bender I
did a video for it so I'll link it at
the end of this the large ship Landing
seems like it belongs to the evil region
character this is actually Zack Snyder
talking about the film with Michael
giacino who just got done Direct
werewolf by night for Marvel there's a
community on a planet a farming planet
and um these uh there's a bunch of bad
guys um the mother world's armies are in
the area and they need to be fed so they
they come to the village and ask for uh
the village to feed them basically while
they're doing their War uh in that area
of the Galaxy and of course um they are
not uh kind about asking and the result
will probably be the obliteration for
the village and so the villagers decide
to fight and so you know they have to go
out into the Galaxy and collect some
soldiers to Warriors to help because the
movie is two parts and part two is
coming out next year I'm assuming
there'll be some kind of cliffhanger
ending like some WTF moment that they
leave things on the pushes into the
beginning of the second film and to
explain that video game that Zack Snyder
explained is going to be based on the
two movies he said it'll take place
after the events of the movies and
you'll play like a rebel that you can
pick and you go on missions but
generally it's to expand the universe of
Rebel moon like he plans to turn this
into a much bigger Star Wars Universe of
his own at Netflix that he can just play
in so he probably has plans for sequels
for prequels for spin-off movies you get
the idea he already kind of did that
with his army of the Dead franchise of
movies like he released another movie
within that universe that was meant to
spin off from the last one that he just
released generally the trailer looks
really crazy so everybody just post all
your reactions in the comments below
like there's a whole bunch of new IP
that he's trying to introduce here like
a whole bunch of world building that
he's do but you can see the influences
of what used to be a Star Wars movie
like a bunch of Space Nazis with a giant
Empire and emperor that they're all
trying to stand against a bunch of
rebels standing against an Empire big
reminder too my Ahsoka episode 1 video
will post later tonight after they air
the episode but they're airing episode
two back to back my episode 2 video
won't post till Wednesday morning after
that episodes will be one per week there
are eight episodes total just like the
Mandalorian it's meant to be connected
to the Mandalorian it'll take place
right after after the Mandalorian season
3 click here for that Ahsoka episode 1
video I'll update the link as soon as I
post that and click here for that Henry
caval Warhammer trailer for his new
series thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe and I'll see you guys
in the next
[Music]
one